in the last video we had just started to
get into meiosis and to be more precise
meiosis wanted to be even more precise
in that prophase one but we spent a good
bit of time on prophase one because some
interesting things happened some things
happened just like prophase and mitosis
where the nuclear envelope disappears or
starts to disappear you have the the
chromosomes for go into their dense form
that has kind of this classic shape that
you could see from a microscope but what
was unique or what was interesting about
meiosis one and prophase one in
particular is that you have this
chromosomal crossover that it's a pretty
typical thing to happen in meiosis one
and it happens in a fair or tends to
happen in a fairly clean way where
homologous sections of these homologous
pairs cross over so they tend to they
these these these sections of the
chromosome tend to code for the for the
for the same genes they're just
different variants of those same genes
they might have different alleles and
once again this just adds more variation
as we get into sexual reproduction so
it's kind of a neat thing that happens
here but now let's continue with meiosis
and in particular meiosis one and you
could guess what the next phase is going
to be called it is metaphase one
metaphase
metaphase one and it has some
similarities with metaphase and mitosis
so in metaphase one so let me draw my
cell
so
this is the cellular
membrane right over there i have my
centrosomes which are now going to play
more significant roles
the nuclear membrane is now gone
and just like in metaphase and mitosis
my chromosomes are going to line up
along the along here i'll draw it kind
of this up down axis so let's do that so
you have this one
right over here
this is one chromosome
two sister chromatids and we had the
chromosomal crossover so it has a little
bit of pink here i'm gonna take a little
bit of time to switch colors a little
bit more frequently and then you have
the one at least most of which you got
from your mother
but there's been a little bit of
chromosomal crossover over here as well
so let me draw that
let me draw that and then you have this
one and just for the sake of
so
you have this one this chromosome from
your father
it is replicated so it's now two sister
chromatids and this one from your mother
and i'm not going to show the
chromosomal cross over here maybe didn't
happen over here
no homologous recombination over here
so these are i guess shorter
now let me draw the centromeres the
centromeres i've started doing in this
blue color
so the centromeres
the centromeres
and then the centrosomes you have these
microtubules that start they can push
the centrosomes away from each other but
they also attach at the kinetochores to
the chromosomes
to the chromosomes just like that
so and these are you know the
microtubules you'll see people just talk
about oh these connect and they and
they're able to move things around this
i find this incredible that you just
have a bunch of proteins through just
kind of chemical and and and and
thermodynamic processes
are able to do really interesting things
like like move chromosomes from to
different parts of the cell so that we
eventually can get these gametes that
can
participate in sexual reproduction this
is an amazing thing and you know it's
it's kind of it's developed over
billions of years of of of evolution but
it's it's just it's just mind-boggling
to think about the complexity and not
all of this is completely understood
exactly how this works i mean you have
these kind of motor proteins that help
move the chromosomes along the these
these microtubules can elongate and
shorten in interesting ways so it's a
really fascinating process but anyway
this is what's happening in metaphase
one now you can probably guess what
happens after that we then move to
anaphase 1. so let me
we now go to anaphase 1. i'll write that
over here
anaphase
anaphase 1
and just like in anaphase and mitosis
over here
the chromosomes start getting pulled
apart except for one significant
difference and this is actually a very
significant difference in mitosis in
mitosis the sister chromatids get pulled
apart the sister chromatids get pulled
apart to become two daughter chromosomes
that does not happen in anaphase one in
anaphase one the sister chromatids stay
together it's the homologous pairs that
get pulled apart so let me draw that so
this homologous pair up here gets pulled
apart the two sister chromatids do not
get pulled apart here so you have this
one is getting pulled
onto this side
so this one's getting pulled onto this
side it has a little bit
from the original
so a little bit of that right over there
and then you have this one getting
pulled on this side
so
draw the best i can
the colors all right so it looks like
that oh it's nice to have that it's kind
of easy to keep track of because these
switch colors like that and then you
have this one getting pulled on this
side
this one getting pulled on this side and
finally
this one
getting pulled
on to that side and let me draw the
centrosomes
so that's my oops centrosome and once
again it's pulling
it's or i guess you could say the
chromosomes being moved and these things
are pushing each other apart the two
centrosomes might be pushing apart to
get to the opposite ends
of the actual cell but they're bringing
there's all sorts of interesting
mechanisms that are bringing along these
microtubules
bringing the chromosomes once again
splitting the homologous pairs and how
they split is is random you know this
this pink one could have been on the
right side this orange one could have
been the left side or vice versa and
once again this adds via this adds uh
this adds more uh kind of variation
amongst the gametes so even all of the
all of the resulting gametes that get
produced they all will have different
genetic information so this is anaphase
one you're pulling these apart and then
you can imagine what happens in
telophase one
so telophase one
telophase
telophase one
telophase one and this is this is fairly
analogous to what happens in mitosis in
telophase
so now you have your cytokinesis
is beginning
so
and actually it might even begin earlier
in mitosis it happens as early as
anaphase at least the cytokinesis is
starting but you're starting to see that
the
these two things the the
the homologous pairs are fully split
apart and they're at opposite ends and
actually they could begin to they can
begin to unravel into their chromatin
state so this one
began to unravel into its chromatin into
its chromatin state it has a little bit
of the magenta whoops it has a little
bit
of
the magenta right over here
this is unraveling as well
this
is unraveling like that once again
towards chromatin state the cellular the
new and let me do the other ones as well
so
this is
this one right over here
it's beginning to unravel
this one over here
beginning to unravel it's got a little
bit of orange on it
it's got a little bit of orange on it
the nuclear membrane begins to form
again
the nuclear
membrane begins to form again
in some ways it's reversing what
happened in prophase one where the
nuclear membrane disappeared and the and
the chromosomes condensed
and let me draw
let me draw
this is centrosomes which are outside of
the nuclear membrane
just like that and the microtubules are
also dissolving
the microtubules are also dissolving and
you have your cytokinesis
so your cytokinesis so these separate
the separate into
two
cells so once again when we did the
overview of of meiosis
we said look the first phase of meiosis
you go from a diploid a diploid germ
cell to two
haploid cells and these aren't quite our
end product yet this right over here
what we have just gone through what we
have just gone through all of this
combined that we have just gone through
this is meiosis one
and in the next video we're going to go
through meiosis ii whoops i didn't mean
to do that
this is
so let's see all of this
is meiosis one let me write that in a
different color in bold
so this is all
meiosis
meiosis one here and you can see each of
these cells now have a haploid number
they they now have the haploid
haploid number of two chromosomes each
now each of those two chromosomes do
have two sister chromatids and as we'll
see meiosis ii which is very similar to
mitosis is going to split up the sister
chromatids from each of these
chromosomes which gives us two daughter
chromosomes so we're gonna see that over
here so your haploid number here is two
you have two chromosomes here and you
have two chromosomes there and we'll
explore meiosis two in the next video